donner envie aux gens d'aller voir le
film faire passer une émotion auprès du
public c'est le but du métier
d'affichiste on va voir le film et on
essaie de s'en imprégner on essaie d'en
tirer ce
qui tout ce que l'on peut sortir comme
visuel qui puisse attirer le monde il
faut faire moi je dis je fais
l'affiche du film que j'aimerais aller
voir alors si c'est un film dans la
catégorie de film que j'aime fficher et
des fois mieux
je m je m'y attache un peu plus c'est le
hasard qu' a amené à ce métier enfant il
était passionné par les affiches de
cirque il a toujours côtoyé des peintres
et été fasciné par le cinéma Michel
Landy réalisera plus de 1000 affiches
pour le 7e art dont celle-ci datant de
1985 un simple voile sur le visage de
Nastasia Kinski du blanc et le titre
harem d'Arthur Jof loin des contraintes
de l'époque où les noms et visag des
acteurs principaux devaient apparaître
pendant un an j'ai j'ai patogé dans ce
dans ce système là j'avais même pas vu
film j'avais le scénario et puis un jour
j'avais tellement marre je vais faire
une affiche blanche avec trois fois rien
comme ça on
verra et ça s'adaptait bien avec le
voile de harem har je je suis rentré
chez moi en 2 minutes j'avais fait un
petit croquis et j'ai fait ça une audace
récompensée par un César le premier pour
la profession Michel Landy croquera plus
affiches de grands films qui sont à
découvrir lors de cette exposition une
autre manière de se plonger dans
l'histoire du
cinéma